Kevon we know you do documentary
workshops you just finished one of the
writers store what are some of the
questions that your most frequently
asked during these interactive
documentary workshops
well probably the number one question is
how do you fund a documentary and that's
always the most difficult aspect of it I
found that they're very interested in
doing a documentary obviously at a lower
price point if there's especially if
they're just starting so we've developed
a budget where I can show people how for
five or ten thousand dollars a micro
budget including buying the equipment
you can actually go out and make a
documentary now that's if you can do a
lot of the roles yourself so if you can
teach yourself how to be the cameraman
and the sound person or the editor or do
the color grading or the scoring if
you're a one-man band you can certainly
do it for very little money if you're
doing a documentary on your neighbor or
somebody is that you know that's
interesting and you don't have a lot of
travel on a lot of other crew positions
so I get asked a lot about budget and
then I get asked a lot about well how do
you actually start and and we go we take
them through the entire process you have
to have a topic that interests you that
will sustain your interest for six
months or six weeks or four years you
know in the case of searching for sugar
man you you need something that really
you can stay with for a long time
because these things sometimes the
funding comes in a little little pieces
and it can be a long process so I'm
asked a lot about funding about how you
start and just basically about the nuts
and bolts of how do you construct how do
you build this documentary speaking of
subjects for your documentary is there
some place that sort of like the
Craigslist for documentarians when it
comes to finding subjects or is it just
matter of observation people that do
documentaries are just sort of lawyers
and they find interesting yeah no it's
just it's like really I mean it's just
where what you see that interests you
you know when I was starting the movie I
did called border war it was a time in
Los Angeles and still going on when we
started to see a bunch of activity on
the border with cartels with human
smugglers and drug smugglers
and when I was trying to fund the film
in Washington DC they weren't seeing the
same level of concern and I was a little
bit ahead of the curve on that and they
were saying we don't see any border war
what's what are you talking about
there's nothing going on on the border
so it's but it's really observing around
you what interests you what will again
what will sustain you and so everything
I'm just walking down the street and
seeing are you into cars that you wanted
to vintage planes are you into you know
obscure musician like $6.00 odd Regas
for sugar man that has an amazing story
a comeback story so it's just anything
in life that you think is a story that
you want people to to know and that you
could communicate to people and maybe
bring a better understanding to a topic
a cause a historical event that you want
to revisit like Errol Morris did with
the fog of war anything that piques your
interest in that that you want to tell
the story about how is documentary
filmmaking evolved you look at something
like Grey Gardens which was beautiful in
its own right but then you see something
like searching for sugar man
and it seems like filmmaking nowadays is
so much faster the editing is just
quicker how have we changed as an
audience so that filmmaking is what it
is in terms of this fast cutting well
it's it is it reflects the same kind of
a attention span that all forms of
filmmaking commercial making television
all of that is become faster so Greg
Gardens is going to look slow so yes
everything is faster if you look at Grey
Gardens it is of a different era and
it's also cinema verite which is
supposedly a flight now fly-on-the-wall
style of filmmaking some would argue
that you're never a fly on the wall the
minute you have a cameraman in a room
you're influencing the events but we
talk about different styles of
documentaries and in the class and
cinema verite is certainly one of the
earlier forms of documentary filmmaking
where you're just observing an event
searching for sugar man is something
much what's much more constructed or
you're adding visual and oral
textures to it you're using music in a
very dramatic way you're using sound
effects in a very dramatic way
a graphics animation errol morris does
the same thing with his montages you're
actually constructing scenarios to
support your story that are completely
constructed completely created by the
filmmaker there's a several sequences in
the fog of war album errol morris takes
what normally would have been just a
picture of a b-29 over tokyo but because
he likes to construct his documentaries
he'll cut the plane out he'll make the
props spin around and he'll he'll just
do things that kind of take you to a
different place so you're observing it
in a different way it's more of an
entertainment style but it's also more
of a you're kind of looking at it in a
different way than perhaps the
documentary you would see on BBC about
world war ii so there are different
styles that the cutting is faster today
no doubt about it and the other document
is we talk about you know so there was a
cinema very cinema verite which is
observational then there's something
that might be called participatory which
is the kind of filmmaking that Michael
Moore does or Morgan Spurlock where the
filmmaker doesn't pretend that he's a
fly on the wall in fact it's the exact
opposite he they become part of the
action they're a character in their own
movie and then there's the more routine
or documentary we see on television is
like frontline now that's kind of an
expository style where you have the
voice of God narrator taking you down
the path Ken Burns does that as well
so we look at the different styles of
documentaries and we also look at in
every one of those forms things are fast
if things do move quicker and yet
sometimes you can you can play against
that and slow it down
to effect so there's always of context
but you know the way you're you're
shooting and cutting a documentary do
you think of documentaries such as Krum
would have the same appeal as it did
back in the 90s as it does now knowing
that that things have changed anybody
can have access to iMovie ten-year-olds
or teaching people on YouTube how to
edit creme was a brilliant documentary I
wouldn't change one frame Krum if I
released it today it's
the thing about any of these
documentaries is it's about storytelling
I don't care how fast you cut or how you
shoot it or what you shoot it on crime
was beautifully made
I had told a great story was well
constructed and that's that's another
thing that people ask in these classes
is and they need to understand is that
the essence of any of this is
storytelling it's it's not about kind of
you know all the other stuff is great
and will have an impact on the film but
you have to be telling a compelling
story
Krum had a beginning a middle and an end
absolutely fascinating characters great
lead character so I you know I wouldn't
change one bit of crime and I think it
would be just as successful and
obviously he went on to do feature films
he had the chops
he had the storytelling chops to go on
and do feature films that being said
Kevin what is a three act structure for
a documentary film isn't that
manipulating reality in some times yes
and no I mean all storytelling you know
this was a a lesson that I was taught
one time I was in a meeting with Peter
Guber and I was pitching a show and I
think he was preparing his book tell to
win which is about what he calls the
emotional transportation business and
he's his claim I think it's true is that
all entertainment whether it's a
documentary or a commercial or a feature
film dramatic film the audience expects
to be taken from one point when they
walk into the theater or turn on the TV
to another place into a final place at
the end they want to go on a ride
somewhere and so all filmmakers I think
oh it to their audience to tell some
kind of story that has a beginning
middle and an end so whether you
construct it consciously or not you just
you when you think about it all stories
whatever you do the story of you coming
over here to talk to me today
I mean that has a beginning a middle and
then that's just the way we do things so
I don't think you're constructing
anything if you following a character
and you meet them and you're you're
doing this film for some reason you find
an interesting character and here's
where they are at well if you follow
them for any length of time you're going
to see their life change and maybe maybe
they're trying to get some
when you meet them that's why you're
interested them interested in them in
the beginning so in act 2 they're going
to be trying to get that object and
perhaps at the end of two yes or no
you know they they'll either get it or
they'll come up against something that
they might not be able to surmount and
act 3 you're going to see whether they
get it or not in in border war I had
five main characters and each of them I
can each of them had three acts and this
was just by being around them for a
certain amount of time there was a young
woman I followed she had lost her
husband who was a LA County deputy
sheriff he had pulled over a man on the
freeway the man shot him and killed him
he was an illegal immigrant he fled back
to Mexico so this young woman that's act
1 for her act 2 is she's trying to find
this man
and I caught up with her during act 2
and during the course of six months I
see her try every avenue including
writing the president United States and
meeting with him to try to bring this
guy back from Mexico to get justice for
her family and for her husband Act three
and it's just it's a stroke of fortune
during our filming time they actually
found the guy in Mexico and brought him
back so that was her Act three and
completely unconstructed by me but
something that fits in that 3x structure
and and I was able to find those three
acts even in very very small ways for
these other characters you might not
think they were three acts but they're
actually three x somebody else was a
border agent who in the beginning I see
him do his job luma Haida the crisis at
the end of Act two is he actually gets
assaulted by a vehicle that's a
vehicular assault on a federal agent by
a coyote a human smuggler and act three
they find out who the guy is so that was
another three act arc so you'll find
these things in life as you follow
characters around and create
documentaries you'll find your acts
structures and the weather and in
constructed or documentaries and ones
what you actually construct yes you
actually will make them in the fog of
war again l Morris is asked asking
Robert McNamara to tell the story but
Morris knows when he's telling the story
that there is a beginning in the middle
Internet
and McNamara knows it too when he tells
the story of his involvement with the
Vietnam War so you know beginning his
involvement what happened during the war
and what he thinks about it now that's
three acts so I think you could find
them surprisingly in almost any scenario
Kevin let's say someone knows what their
quote subject is day one of shooting
what are they doing what are some of the
things that they're doing they're
walking into this person's environment
how are they capturing the mood of this
person's place etc well hopefully you
know you've established some sort of
relationship going in and you've talked
to them either in person around the
phone and you've had a number of emails
and you you know to get them to say yes
I'll let you be a part of my life and
fill me for any you know whatever amount
of time but you have to know you're
gonna be doing it probably a lot of
interviews you know maybe but the first
one if you want to get something in the
can so to speak and get in a good hour
and in the can you got to go over and
set a nice you know scene make them
comfortable kind of you've kind of
talked about what kind of questions
you're gonna ask them you don't need to
show them anything sometimes if they ask
for a list of questions if I'm doing a
television show I'll generally not want
to do that but if they insist I'll give
them some sample questions that's not a
big big thing make them comfortable and
just have a conversation with them you
know let them know that we can start and
stop and do this again you know if they
don't like their answer they want to you
know you know amend something so you're
gonna get you know hopefully you can get
you know just to start the ball rolling
get a nice interview for an hour or so
don't wear him out don't do three hours
just get an hour and get some b-roll
around their house may be going down to
what they're doing that's maybe related
or not even related to the topic you're
talking about but you're trying to
create a character you're trying to
create a person so you want to see them
living you want to see them doing their
things so even if this is a show about a
Vietnam veteran or something you know
his family's part of his life possibly
so you're gonna show the family you're
gonna get to know them if they're part
of the documentary you just trying to
you know gather all the materials that
are really in their world their
environment their house their work their
friends if they're applicable so you're
just trying to get
these are building blocks you need
because you need a lot of them you're
going to need you know depending on what
the show is you might need you know a
lot of personal stills you might need
archival material but it can get to that
you know it's a whole different topic
but you just really want to gain their
trust and begin this process because
you're probably going to want to go back
several times as they go through their
life or chase this dream or whatever
you're you're filming when you're in top
of your documentary you want to going to
want to go back and catch up with these
people in terms of border war which we
mentioned before I would periodically
visit the widow of this deputy sheriff
see where she is watch her make the
phone calls to her congressman and
Senator and saying please let's try to
get this guy back from Mexico we know
where he's hiding
they won't extradite him we've talked to
the president I've written letters but I
see her writing letters so you know you
get your b-roll you're gathering all of
the elements you need to create this
story because you're not going to want
to just show a talking head for 90
minutes you want to you need coverage
you need to see them doing things you
need archival photos and you need them
you know just making it visually
interesting to the audience so you you
know so you have that that coverage so
that's just one part of building this
this this building that's gonna twist
and turn as you the more material you
gathered so you know I always tell my
students that I'll make an outline at
the beginning but I'm you have to be
completely open to it twisting and
turning because the more interviews you
get in the more oh you learn things you
find out things maybe you don't need
that extra interview maybe this takes
the story in a whole new direction so
you need to get enough extra interview
so it's like building a building but
where the blueprint is always changing
and it should change and you should
react to it you don't want to be in a
box and think this is exactly how my
documentary is gonna look and then have
all these things come in and make it
better and say no I can't put that in
because that wasn't in my outline now
you want to be free and make this a
sculpture and build it as it goes and
there's you know there's a there's a
alex gibney movie out on julian assange
now that I believe
at some point in filming you know
assange does not cooperate but at some
point the filmmaking team figures out
that this guy is very complex and they
can either call him a maniac or a genius
or whatever but he's got a massive ego
and and he's difficult to work with his
people is so that kind of takes it n
different it adds a layer of context to
these characters and the situation so
you know you have to be open to the
story twisting and turning as you go and
that includes the three-act structure
because yeah and and but with a 3x
structure no I'm not so rigid that I
have to say everything is 3x I might
have six acts I might have you know in
broken promises which was a movie I made
about the United Nations on its 60th
anniversary I also followed several
different characters and I wanted to
tell I wanted to tell a story of
peacekeepers through people that were
affected on the frontlines of these
missions so I wanted to get in love I
wanted to go through personal stories I
wanted to find personal stories that
would illuminate larger issues like oil
for food or the shrub the massacres
revenues or the genocide Rwanda I wanted
to find people who were actually there
on the ground to tell me their their
view of what happened so you know you're
always trying to relate it to personal
stories large topics but if you can
relate it to personal stories that will
help so it's not always it sometimes
it's not three acts you know in the
conventional dramatic way sometimes it's
six acts it depending on how many
characters you have and perhaps the
entire movie is three acts but you
sliced it so that little characters can
come in and leave and and they there the
story can wrap up and it's soon going
toward a larger three-act frame on that
United Nations movie was here was what
it was created to be in 1945 which was
the world's workshop for peace largely
created by the United States what
happened in act 2 lots of good things
happen with UNICEF and what have you and
feeding the poor but a lots of bad
things happened too with scandals and
peacekeeper rape scandals and well for
food again and then these various
problems and corruption so that's act 2
and act 3 is now we're just going to
burn the
building down no how do you how do you
try to fix it how what are the ideas to
try to bring them back to that original
ideal of 1945 to be the world's workshop
for peace so those were within that
three act structure the larger one I had
multiples you know looks tinier acts
within that as I follow these characters
you know as they as they show us how
they've related to these various UN
programs
what would a filmmaker need to know
about shooting an interview in terms of
like setting up their camera let's say
they're using a DSLR like the bowmen
using now what are some of the tips that
they should be aware of well you you
number one you'll you you'll know with a
DSLR you know you're gonna have a
beautiful picture because of the large
sensor but essentially it's still a
still camera not a video camera
especially when it comes to audio audio
is your biggest workaround now you have
you dual a dual system which is like an
old 16 millimeter film camera with an
auger you know tape recorder so you have
to sync up the sound in the picture
because you can't really when you use an
HD SLR you're not gonna bring the audio
straight into the camera generally
speaking unless you really you know
that's your gonna get over modulating
the audio and you're gonna get all kinds
of problems you're gonna want to do it
separately so that's a workaround there
the ergonomics on a DSLR are not the
same as the shoulder on a camera that's
is which is why you see all these
incredible rigs they come up with what
you're generally speaking almost more
expensive than the cameras you know by
various vendors where you can have
shoulder mounts and it's all about
stabilizing it because these most of
these image stabilization lenses are
still still camera lenses they're not
the same as a video image stabilized
video lens so you know I used to think
it was a very good handheld camera
person and I'm you know for a director I
do some of my own shooting but just
generally b-roll and stuff I hire you
know really good DPS and operators but
this the first time I operated my Canon
DSLR was at a rally the downtown rally
immigration rally and I did a lot of
stuff in the crowd and I brought it back
and it was horrible it was so jittery
like I couldn't believe I shot it but
the point was it's not image stabilized
the same way as a video cameras so you
know get this thing rock-solid be
prepared for this
work around but you know you're gonna
have spectacular images they're really
amazing what you can get out of the Hg
SLR is now going back to finding more
about your quote subject is there
sometimes too much to know ahead of time
can you've got all of the good stuff out
in one phone call and then once you meet
with them in person they're sort of flat
yes that happens you want to save it's
gentling that so much in the phone call
but when you arrive on location as your
crew is setting up or you're setting up
and you're starting to talk and maybe
they're starting to offer stuff you
don't want to be talked out you don't
want them to give up too much you know
see I've often said you know what let's
let's save it for the interview because
this is really good I don't want you to
feel like you're repeating yourself I
want you to be fresh with it and
spontaneous so yeah you don't you don't
want to you don't want to get you know
spoil it you don't want to get too much
out generally with the phone call it's
gonna be days before so that's not a
problem but when you arrive make sure
they're fresh and you know don't don't
have them waste any any any great
nuggets that you might regret not
getting and conversely what if they're
too on what if they're in actor pitch
mode and they're just too large for the
camera and they're regurgitating all of
their sort of press notes just tell them
that you're you're you just tell them
just to calm down most people you'll
find want to be directed in some way
because they're not professionally doing
they're not professional on-camera
documentary subjects you know so they
might not know they'll appreciate a
piece of constructive criticism that
want you to you know make them look good
they'll want you to bring them down so
they'll they'll they'll appreciate that
so you just very nicely say you know
what let's just have a conversation like
we did on the phone and like we did
before we'd roll the camera so that's
generally not an issue you're not going
to find too many people who are not
professional people you know being too
up I think they'll be generally it's the
other way around it's bringing them up
to a conversational level and learning
to speak you know when in full sentences
and because generally if specially if
you're off camera you know you want
somebody to be able to repeat the
question and the answer that takes a
little time but that's that's generally
more
was bringing people up to the level of
what you wanted rather than bringing
them down and if they're too big if
they're not answering their line again
just be very honest with them and say
they're just react in a very nice way
just react the question in a way that
you'll get at what you need to get at
you kind of you know you're not going to
know everything they're gonna tell you
but you're gonna know what they might
have told you before on the phone so
just remind them you know you told me
the other day that this happened and
that happened can you tell me that story
and they'll tell you you know so if they
don't want to they wouldn't be there if
they don't if they you know if they
don't want to be there so if by saying
yes they're generally going to you know
be very amenable to doing whatever you
know whatever you need to get that
answer out that that you that you that
they told you before you're not creating
anything you're not asking them to to
falsify anything you're just reminding
them that you've told me the other day
that this happened can you tell me that
story that's generally all you need to
do in terms of people that maybe are I
mean saying you know and hesitating do
you sometimes leave that in because
that's just a natural style for them or
people who are too fidgety
you know I with fidgety I'll tell them
you're drifting or something but with
the arms in the hands if that's how they
talk they talk you'll clean that up and
editing you know you don't want to you
know you want to give them so much you
know the criticism that they're gonna
freeze up you know if that's the way
they talk that's the way they talk and
you'll you'll work with it and again it
might be part of the the context of the
answer you know searching for the answer
might be part of that answer itself
where they were hesitant or they're
duplicitous or whatever they might be
that maybe that's part of the whole
thing so you might want that but as if
it's just an eminent and generally when
you go through your edit you know you're
gonna be cleaning up if you have enough
coverage you're gonna be cleaning a lot
of that stuff up can you tell us the
difference between a ten thousand dollar
documentary versus a hundred thousand
five hundred thousand two million what
do you get at each price point well at
ten thousand dollars you're not going to
get a lot you're not you you can make a
documentary for ten thousand dollars but
you'll have to do either a lot of the
crew positions yourself or have people
that will you know volunteer their time
to do it for you so you're gonna have to
ask for a lot of freebies but you can do
a documentary for ten thousand you can
buy that camera that we're shooting on
today for you know three thousand with
the lens there abouts
and you're gonna be able to buy your
zoom recorder and you're going to be
able to buy you know a few lights and
what have you and so you can get in
business for probably under under five
and then if you're not traveling and
you're just shooting you know in your
area then it's you can and it's your own
gear you can shoot as many days as you
want if you're not hiring crews so you
can do it on ten thousand dollars but at
each price point if you go next go up to
the hundred thousand dollar documentary
now you're going to be able to pay
people what their normal industry
rate is you know on the ten thousand
dollar mentor you're not gonna bring out
a makeup person but for between six and
eight hundred dollars a day you just
can't do that you can't buy a full HD
crew for thirty five hundred dollars a
day rental with Sam so but a hundred
thousand dollars you're gonna get the
full HD crew at their normal rate about
thirty five hundred west with sound
that's with lights that's with if you
need a lighting director and his grip
you know cart that's seven hundred bucks
or to a thousand dollars you're gonna be
able to afford that you're gonna be able
to afford a gaffer if you need it just
to make everything look better you're
gonna be able to afford now maybe needle
drop music that's royalty-free from a
music library now you can bring a
composer in not at the highest end but
for fifteen or seventeen thousand
dollars maybe one hundred thousand I
wouldn't do that
two hundred fifty I would bring in that
that level of composer but so you're
just gonna be able to travel a bit if
you have interviews across the country
you need for your show you still need to
know where to economize in other words
do you need a hundred thousand dollars
you're not flying your DP you know
director photography to New York you
you're getting a local crew in some
cases you might have to even hire a
local stringer director if it's not a
huge interview to do the interview for
you sometimes you've directed over Skype
or what have you if you want to be you
know if you want to be sure I've done
that many times so four hundred thousand
dollars you'll get the travel you get
more crew days more shoot days you'll be
able to buy some clips some archival
footage you go up next to go up to five
hundred thousand it's more
saying more prep more research more
shoot days more travel everybody gets
paid industry standards for what they're
doing better music better graphics
better color grading so and on enough to
million dollars you can you can now
maybe if you had a pop song you wanted
to buy very expensive to license music
but you'll have a better Original Score
you might even buy some some songs again
better more travel more prep archival
footage I've spent on some films over
$100,000 on clips and stills and that's
what you're going to get either at a
five hundred or two million dollar price
point you're going to be able to go to
Getty and say I need you know 188 Stills
and they'll make a deal with you I need
you know 46 minutes of archival footage
of this event you know I did a movie
call nine days that changed the world
where pope john paul ii visits poland in
1979 and sparks this movement that
becomes the Solidarity movement which
eventually takes down communism in
Poland I needed a lot of archival
footage we found some that the Polish
Bishops Council had shot that was
unearthed in a in a room and poet and
polish television that had been sitting
in Cannes for 30 years but I still had
to buy other stills and clips so that
adds up and you know you're gonna have
so out of two million price point you
can have 100 to 150 thousand dollar clip
budget or more so those are the various
things it's it really comes down to prep
and shoot days and how you pay your crew
and travel and music and graphics and
everything that makes your and that
makes your film more and more polished
so it's possible to be a one-man band
but it's not going to get you very far
in terms of legitimizing the documentary
because just the production value no no
I wouldn't say that at all I would say
you could make that's the great thing
about these cameras and and say if you
buy an HD LSR and you buy a subscription
to Adobe the cloud now for forty nine
dollars a month now you have access to
their entire editing suite their After
Effects Photoshop you know Premiere Pro
so you can and if you teach yourself
though
skills you can do all that and if you
teach yourself out around the camera you
can do that now the thing that the cuffs
nothing is finding the great story it's
always about finding the great story you
know you can have what if your neighbor
is this old-time movie actress that has
a great story to tell and he's just
sitting in her house waiting for you to
come over there and film her that cost
you nothing so the story costs you know
if you have access and access is another
thing we could talk about that's the
whole that's the critical nature along
with the story structure and knowing how
to tell a story it's access to your
subject in that case on the $10,000
price point if you have a story with
heart and soul that you've shot you
could have made that four five hundred
dollars conceivably if you had your
camera and you never didn't buy anything
and you actually learned all these
skills and did it yourself might take
you a year or two to do but you could
that could be just as good as any
documentary that cost a million dollars
it's what's the story what's the human
story look at Sugarman now that was
that's four hundred thousand dollars but
he was actually he had it he had the nub
of that movie for about eighty I guess
before he went and he met with the
producer one of the producers of burr a
man on wire I think in London and he
showed him just a little bit and the guy
said this is magnificent we have to he
was able to complete the funding but the
core of that film was the story and that
was just calling people up they weren't
charging you I don't believe in that
case in most cases not they're not
charging you to tell them for you to
tell their story that you found their
story that's so that's gold that's the
goal that's priceless and it doesn't
matter if you're using a $3,000 camera
or in an air flex to Alexa so you know
it's always about the story and the
storytelling skill really Kevin we know
that crowdfunding is all the rage
Kickstarter IndieGoGo and other sites
that are wonderful but what if someone
does not want to crowd fun it's not as
easy as just posting the campaign
there's a lot of work it's like a
full-time job can you talk about other
ways of funding grants what have you
well I've been lucky to find private
money to fund my documentaries but
there are more traditional sources and
that's generally teaming up with either
a production company or a network and
that's a traditional why you going to
picture Network HBO what-have-you and
they're going to go into business with
you that's ideally the way you do things
that's not easy either so these other
avenues have come along grants I've
never done because you need the patience
of job to do that that takes forever and
your and the money's coming in in very
small amounts it's possible I have a
good friend doing a documentary now on
WC handy and she received money a grant
money and so she's you know she's been
filming as she goes along so it is
possible the crowdfunding it's also
difficult I've had three friends who
have successfully funded at various
price points up from 35,000 up to
$200,000 and that's very rare but it's
it's doable on crime in Kickstarter or
IndieGoGo and and then there you know
there's there's uh so there's private
individuals that's another form that I
found that's also difficult but it's it
does cut through a lot of the
back-and-forth with grants or networks
or what-have-you so it's that's always
the number one question and and the
toughest thing is how do you get the
money to make these things so you know
it's it's really going out to the
marketplace and finding out what they're
going to say well what's in it for them
can they make money off this enterprise
it's it's are they going to be able to
see the return on their dollar on their
investment so that's why you consider
these things when you're picking your
topics you know you want to you want to
look at the marketplace and say is there
room in the market for this documentary
is there but has there been competition
on this subject if so is there room for
one more if not is was a reason nobody
wanted to do this topic so you're gonna
look at all that you know as you go into
funding but it's always the most
difficult thing there are new ways to do
it I wouldn't say no to the
crowdsourcing because if you have a good
pitch and you have a good idea and you
maybe only need funds to either get
started refinish maybe thirty five or
fifty thousand dollars that's pretty
doable I had some some friends who
needed finishing funds of two hundred
and they raised to ten or so so it is
possible to
to do if you have an appealing subject
let's say though you'd like to go the
route of pitching a network or an
individual that would like to invest in
what do you need to have in place when
you show up I know something like that
they would want to see complete
organization and right in my experience
they don't want they want to see a
written pitch but they don't want it to
be 40 pages they want it to be between
five and ten pages that they can get the
idea of your film that quickly and
nowadays if you could put any kind of
pitch reel together sizzle reel kind of
trailer I know you haven't shot it yet
supposedly but maybe you can maybe for
free on your own dime you can go down to
your subject and get an afternoon with
them and get them on tape and if you
shoot it with your H DSLR and you should
and you cut it on your your cloud
editing system you put it together for
very little and you have their stills
with you can license and you so you put
together a little two-minute pitch movie
along with a five page pitch you that's
all you need you they're gonna get it
from that so at least come in with those
two things and and you have a shot and
quickly just gaining access you know a
wonderful neighbor or someone that works
at a shop right well access is the key
to anything and you know can be on a
small level with somebody that you want
to make a documentary about and you have
a relationship with or it can be a
larger thing where you have to really
take months to gain that access on
border war we were embedded by secretary
Chertoff and met homeland security we
were embedded with a group of undercover
agents in Nogales Arizona and to get
that access took months but what that
gave the film was this incredible look
at what happens on the border with the
constant stream of human and drug
smuggling coming over and without that
access that whole section of the film
would have not not had been there than
without that really brought the viewer
into the smugglers tunnels and into the
safe houses and across the border to see
how it all happens so you know access is
everything same with broken promises my
movie on the United Nations like you
know I had to go to the United Nations
and sit down with him and convinced them
that I was going to do it
that was going to be constructively
critical of their organization but
constructive and fair and in fact giving
them the last word which is what we did
and but you have to gain trust and get
by gaining that trust during those
meetings with the United Nations we were
given access to film in the entire
facility and I don't recall another
documentary at least before since
there's been a few feature films but we
had access to film in the General
Assembly and the Security Council rooms
and and it's just full access to the to
the premises which was invaluable and
gave the film the look that we were
looking at going after so access whether
it's your neighbor or the United Nations
or department of homeland security
access is really what's gonna make your
story in terms of gaining trust I think
I heard John Sayles say about mate whan
that he had to do quote the porch time
he had to you know go into the community
and talk to people and really make them
realize that he was an OK guy he wasn't
there to exploit that
mm-hmm so what is porch time with the
United Nations I mean how do you court a
relationship like that well it was as
simple as you know calling them up and
finding out what's the protocol for
proposing that we can do a film and
shoot on the premises and you find out
their protocols and you have to write
your letters and then you have to go to
New York and you sit down with their
team in a room and you have to answer
their questions and this bottom line is
they'll check you out and you know maybe
they think well somebody's gonna do a
film on on us I've looked and checked in
to this team and we like this team and
we're gonna trust this team to do a fair
job it really comes down to that so
comes down to meeting with these people
and gaining their trust and and this was
all around an event a 60th anniversary
so there's gonna be some press coverage
they knew was coming and they knew they
had to pick and choose who they would
allow to be in on the premises turns out
that the our film was quite quite
critical very critical of the
organization but it was always meant to
be you know a kind of a meditation on
how do you make it better how do you
improve it so they got that from from
our conversation that's why they allowed
to film there in terms of gaining trust
with some let's say an obscure artist
and you pass them on the street and you
notice them for months how would one do
that without sort of exploiting them or
is is there a very fine line between
that well you it's always about making
contact I mean if you if you want to
tell their story they have to trust that
that they're gonna tell it in a fair
fashion they want to have or they want
to be able to say I do want my story
told or not if they don't they don't but
you just have to gain you have to
establish contact I mean it's it's
basically what you it's the whole
process of filmmaking is about making
connections with people too and telling
stories and exposing things to larger
groups of people so the whole process is
about communicating with people and that
begins with communicating with your
subject hello can I make a film I'd like
to make a film about you and then you'd
go from there
it's almost like asking someone out on a
date so you kind of take that one that
one leap and and you're not as simple as
that hey man well yeah it could be as if
you know it depends on your comfort
level it could be as simple sending an
email which is fairly safe now like
hello I'm very interested in your story
I'm a fan of your work and you know what
here's here's what I've done in the past
I mean an example recently Errol Morris
did another film with another former
secretary of defense this time Donald
Rumsfeld about the Iraq war well he the
contacted Rumsfeld offices and he just
gave them he said look here I made a
film called the fog of war with McNamara
take a look at that you can see if you
can trust me or not come to Washington
DC and we'll film and I'll put together
a little piece and I'll show it to you
and if you like it we'll proceed if not
that's fine we'll walk our we'll go our
separate ways I believe that's the way
the story went but that's the way
sometimes you have to establish trust
you're not out to burn anybody you're
here to make a film and and and and
communicate and and put something out
whether it's critical or not you know
these people you want them to cooperate
with you so you want to say I'm gonna
there's no nothing no games goin on here
here's what I'm doing you want to be a
part of this and here's you can look
into my past and you can trust me or you
can not trust me that's fine but I would
like to do a film and then you can just
go from there
Kevin what's the best way to handle
release forms for your documentary film
and then how important is it to actually
have those release forms well it's it's
critical to have the release forms
you're not going to have a film without
the release forms you won't get your you
know insurance without the release forms
you won't get a release you won't get a
distribute you won't get anything
without him so you have to have them now
there's certain parameters about group
shots and events and rallies where you
don't have to have crowds for signing
release forms but your principle
sit-down interviews you have to get
release forms and I have been meticulous
throughout my career of getting release
forms and generally you want to get them
signed before you roll the interview and
then the one time I did not was the
lesson that you know learned and that
was the case where I was interviewing
someone who had experienced a great loss
and it took a long time to get them to
the point where they said yes to do the
interview and so was a very much of a
kind of a evolving relationship of trust
to get to the point where they would sit
down in front of the camera and allow
and allow us into their life and I never
really and I always knew I should get
that thing signed but it was always I
didn't want to break this kind of this
mood we were getting in that we could
trust each other and we did the
interviews and we did the story and it
turned out to be much bigger than we
ever thought and I finally went back
because I've established such a close
relationship for this person that we're
posting the film I had all the other
releases signed and the normal fashion I
do but I had not gotten this one done
yet and I went back to get the interview
and this person said no they were not
going to sign the release and this story
was so central to my film that without
it the film would have crumbled in that
section so they said no I will not sign
the next thing I know I get a phone call
from an attorney saying they want a
certain amount of money which is a
considerable amount of money and which
we had to pay and to get the release and
but it makes the film but the point is
always get that release signed and you
know you is that it's not a question of
yes or no you have to have a release
you're not going to get you know
distributed without a release
so emails would not be binding in terms
of someone agreeing to it's not even
think of verbal on-camera releases truly
binding they could later they could say
I really didn't understand what I was
saying yes - do you have it on paper and
they sign it they understand that
release form so you have to be very
careful about about release forms you
brought up something interesting crowd
shots I did something the other day on a
subway and everybody was just staring at
the camera and I'm trying to get my
subject I had to use some of that
footage what rights does the public have
in terms of what if someone sees that
and says no you didn't you didn't get a
release from me and I see myself on
camera there well that's a little
different you know crowd shots there's a
federal size of cratan it's not the
Coliseum or it's not a huge rally of
some form on the mall in Washington DC
that's a crowd shot on a subway that's
you if you're being able to pick out
faces that's a different dilemma now
there are there's a lot of rules in this
but you know as long as you weren't
hiding the camera that's one thing in
your favor because they see a camera
that could always turn away so the
camera was present generally speaking
you know you won't know if it's gonna be
on any kind of broadcast TV they're
gonna put up a sign thing if you we're
filming here you give you a consent to
be on camera because we're so you know
that's not a professional level on the
network if you're on a subway I'd be
very careful about that because you are
especially if you're gonna be showing
faces backs of faces and your and your
and your character fine but you know you
can't blame them they're you know
they're down there doing their thing and
you know you're you're going to be
making money off this image probably if
you sell this movie and they're not
consenting they didn't ever never asked
for their consent to be in the shot so
you got to be careful when they eat when
you recognize their face so it's okay
the backs of someone the likeness of
them from far away but yeah exactly as
long as you're not recognizable or if
there's so many and it's a public event
where the news crews are public and your
cameras in the open that's a different
thing you could it's a new more of a
news context